[Música]
la primera vez que me subió tenía 12
años
en ese momento estaba en una sala de
conciertos en suiza
y había una presentación muy especial
con los niños solistas del coro del cual
yo hacía parte
yo tenía un solo preparado y era mi
primera vez
en el momento de cantar mi estrofa y
finalmente tener mi solo
algo pasó yo sentí algo de duda si no
fue el control ante cualquier cosa nunca
enteró que alguien preparado
yo decidí en ese día que no quería
volver a ser solista nunca más ya
subirme a un escenario dije fue un
desastre y ya el escenario no es para mí
yo era una niña muy exigente soy esta
chiquita isla de blanco era una niña muy
perfeccionista y exigente conmigo misma
con los otros y
lo que yo realmente sentí fue que no me
pertenecía estar en ese espacio quiero
solamente para los que son realmente
buenos yo sentía que quería ser tan
buena y tan exitosa con mis hermanos
mayores
suena menor de 5
en el momento de escoger mi profesión yo
pensé bueno tengo un hermano
economista una hermana médica una
arquitecta una psicóloga a mí siempre me
gustan los animales bueno voy a ser
veterinaria quiero que eso a encajar
perfectamente en mi familia
pero bueno la vida siguió yo no estudié
veterinaria y tampoco cumplir la promesa
de no volver a subir a un escenario
nunca más la música siguió siendo parte
de mi vida y las invitaciones para
cantar siguen llegando yo las acepta
porque en realidad es que me encantaba
la música yo en el fondo sí
y que sabía cantar bien
a los 23 años después de haber hecho un
diploma en terapia ocupacional y de
entender que no era eso que quería hacer
de mi vida
yo encontré que la música era lo que yo
quería hacer no era solamente un hobby
para mí y en ese momento me metí a
estudiar en la escuela superior de
música deporte primero en clásico y
después en jazz y empecé a viajar por el
mundo estudiando me fui a barcelona
apostan hice una maestría en bruselas un
intercambio en parís
y de repente también empecé a abrir mi
mente a través de mis viajes
paralelamente a mis estudios
universitarios yo empecé a estudiar
improvisación vocal con una cantante
americana que se llama brian y la música
se hacía de una manera completamente
diferente no había partituras no había
ensayos y improvisábamos la música en el
momento nos mirábamos en los ojos nos
movíamos interactuaremos la música la
hacíamos de manera completamente
espontánea un día a oriana me dijo yo te
recomiendo un ejercicio 20 minutos al
día
cantando y bailando sola yo era muy
rígida corporalmente casi no me movía
cuando cantaba y no lo hice ese
ejercicio en ese momento pero ya la
verdad se estaba encargando de ponerme
en el azar a otra persona en otro
continente que terminaría convenciéndome
a hacer lo mismo
unos años más tarde ya con una carrera
de muchos conciertos por el mundo de
varios discos lanzados yo me fui a me
vine a pasar una temporada en bogotá
estaba en una época de gran gran crisis
personal sentía mucha tristeza mucha
duda mucha decepción con el mundo de la
industria musical
no tenía ganas de cantar empiece a
pensar en hacer otra cosa que no fuera
en la música
un día estaba caminando por el barrio de
la soledad
y me llamó la atención a una tienda de
artesanías y me acerqué me empezó a
hablar un hombre un hombre con unos ojos
azules grandes una presencia muy fuerte
y él me dijo que cuando me miraba y veía
miedo mucho miedo
y yo había llegado ahí por alguna razón
en ese lugar y que me invitaba a ser
unos talleres ahí es en ese mismo
espacio
todo me pareció muy raro yo decidí y me
dijo
talleres acá en esta tienda de 5 metros
cuadrados yo me voy de acá en el momento
que estoy por salir y empieza una lluvia
de esas éticas típicas de bogotá
en que uno se queda completamente
empapado en dos segundos no me fui a
ningún lado pese espera hasta que la
lluvia pase
pasaron como tres horas me quería
hablando con este señor jaime barranco
y el término convenciéndome a dar una
oportunidad a sus talleres yo soy la
idea ya pensando tal es vale la pena
arriesgarme y ver qué es lo que él tiene
para enseñarme está en un momento de
crisis no tenía mucho a perder
al día siguiente me devolví a la tienda
y por dos meses me fui varias veces la
semana a tener clases con él
los ejercicios que me proponían cada uno
me parecía más raro que el otro para que
tengan una idea me tocaba improvisar con
sonidos y movimientos descansa en el
medio de la carrera 19 en el medio del
andén
con sonidos con gente pasando caminando
gente en los buses y en el carro que
paraba en el semáforo justo haría un
semáforo en frente lo que era perfecto
para todos los comentarios que había
y eso fue de lo más incómodo que hubiese
navidad fue salir completamente de mi
zona de confort fue como una terapia de
choque yo que había crecido
identificando lo que está bien y mal lo
que se puede lo que no se puede hacer yo
que vivía preocupada con lo que los
otros pensaban de mí de repente era la
loca bailando descalza en el medio de la
carrera 19 oyendo todo el tipo de
comentarios
jaime me ayudó a entender que mi
vocación si era cantar
pero qué
le tocaba enfrentar a mis miedos más
profundos
el miedo de no ser perfecta
el miedo de equivocarme y fallar
fracasar
el miedo de no agradar a todos yo
entendí que necesitaba encontrar una
confianza más profunda no la que viene
de la aprobación de los otros pero la
que viene desde adentro
a través de mis maestros yo entendí que
había un mundo más allá de los juicios
de las fórmulas mentales
un mundo libre donde uno simplemente se
puede aceptar cómo es
y después de entender que uno puede ser
libre yo no podía dejárselo solamente
para mí yo empecé a sentir que todo este
proceso que había tenido podría
compartirlo con otras personas y ayudar
a transformar a los otros de la misma
manera como esto me había transformado a
mí y entonces empecé a hacer mis propios
talleres de improvisación vocal y de ser
con singh y en estos talleres nosotros
nos conectamos de manera muy profunda
con el momento presente usamos la voz
como una herramienta de juego una
herramienta de autoconocimiento y como
un elemento liberador
más importante que pensar cómo es que yo
voy a sonar es cómo es que puedo hacer
que el otro suene bien
quiero darles una pequeñita demostración
de uno de los ejercicios que hacemos en
estos talleres y para esto tengo a tres
invitados muy especiales tenemos a marie
claire que es terapeuta de medicinas
alternativas para que vean que esto es
para todos no es solamente para
cantantes
tenemos a mariluz que es una cantante ya
nicolás peña que también es cantante
[Aplausos]
necesitamos un voluntario idealmente que
no sea músico
también hablamos perfectos ya tiene
micrófono y todos
yo no soy músico entonces en este
ejercicio que vamos a hacer
se llama five ter y lo que fue inventado
por un amigo que sea magnífico de
holanda
este ejercicio y muchos de los que
hacemos en este trabajo son pasados en
loop en loops un loop es como una frase
musical que se repite por ejemplo
[Música]
y se repite no pueden pero el loop puede
ser cabo
cualquier cosa puede ser un loop
entonces la regla es cuando estoy
volcada para acá canto cuando estoy
volteada la pared
hago silencio que íbamos a estar
volteando los tiempos
ahí vamos
todo lo que va a pasar acá es
enteramente improvisado
[Música]
pero mi mamá
para de vivir para quien quiere comprar
cual quiere cobrar para que quiere
comprar para quien quiere comprar antes
quien quiere comprar
para pérez
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola
y
y la grada de ayala
nada de ella
[Música]
y ahora
ah
cada día
d
aldeas
la verdad
en horas
[Música]
respecto
de cuando en cuando
[Música]
el calor
alor
a los
a luz
al hombre malo
adiós
[Aplausos]
gracias
bueno una de las cosas que trabajamos
acá es perder el miedo del ridículo
primero lugar es buscar cultivar un poco
el gusto arriesgarnos a buscar siempre
nuevos caminos
la vergüenza la pena como ustedes dicen
y también soltar el control
y lo que me pasó cuando tenía 12 años y
canté como solista por primera vez
fue justo sentirme muy molesta incómoda
con esa sensación de pérdida de control
para mí la pérdida de control significo
un fracaso
y yo no hubiera si hubiera realmente
quedado fuera del escenario si hubiera
decidido quedarme mero invisible con
miedo a arriesgarme
miedo a no ser perfecta miedo a
equivocarme yo no estaría acá hoy con
ustedes yo no sería cantante yo no
dejaría talleres
quiero compartirles
un pedazo de una canción mía de mi nuevo
disco la letra dice sacudiendo cada
miedo no solamente marchó sino que danzó
en cadencia con el viento decida por el
tiempo voy y canto y confió fue enfrente
y conmigo llevo el brillo de la luna y
del sol y como no tengo mi banda acá
conmigo lo que nos voy a invitar a que
sean mi banda se animan
e
[Risas]
entonces vamos a hacer yo voy a cantar
este pedacito de canción después de eso
todo va a ser completamente improvisado
ok pero al comienzo lo que les voy a
pedir es que canten solamente una nota
este es el momento que muchos está
empezando no no no yo no sé cantar yo si
canto horrible por favor no me hagas
cantar mejor quedarme afuera invisible
para no dejar no canten todos porque el
efecto colaboración va a ser magia ok
entonces lo que tiene que hacer es
[Música]
y cuando se sientan estudio de respirar
respiren es importante para que
sobrevivan a esta conferencia y vuelven
a cantar
spears
sacudido cada miedo
no son marchó como de su incumbencia
como evento embajada pelota en perfume
y confío muy frente y con mí
no pude dudoso
la habana dio un muelle y yo un muelle y
yo salado un major un major
yo voy a john bayley yo tuve yo sigan un
baby
van a nada ni a nadie
ahí es cuando niño
un vídeo móvil y yo fui y yo
[Música]
los invito a todos
si suban al escenario de sus vidas que
observen sus miedos y que sigan adelante
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah